thank you very much it's a great honor
to have Nancy Pelosi with us and Chuck
Schumer with us and
[Music]
[Applause]
and you want to shut it I am talking
about the last time Chuck you shouldn't
no no no and then you okay that's
alright quickly and we NEET I don't want
to do what you did twenty time John have
called for I will shut down the
government if I don't get my wolf none
of us have you wanna do something you
said okay you want to put that who I
said I'll take okay
keep the government open we're going to
keep it on there if we have borders with
America when don't have borders to do
each other yeah we're not going to give
our members are already below it's not
employ way that we've had in 50 years we
confront unless that's about border
security if we don't have
[Music]
[Applause]
this is horrifying
Trump Pelosi and Schumer are just
carrying an argument as if Mike Pence is
still alive somebody help him
prior to this meeting Madame Tussaud has
rolled in this Mike Pence wax figure
[Music]
I can't explain it to you it was so wild
it goes to show you you get into a
tickle context with a skunk you get a
tinkle all over you
you